[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 Zoe herminia Fernández
comenzamos en Estados Unidos no son los
electores quienes escogen a sus
políticos sino los políticos quienes
escogen a sus votantes cada 10 años
después del censo de población en cada
uno de los 50 estados del país el
partido en el poder puede rediseñar los
mapas electorales para que los distritos
tengan una población de electores más o
menos equivalente pero para asegurarse
de ganar las siguientes elecciones el
partido en cuestión recorta los
distritos a su favor a veces de manera
totalmente ilógica con el objetivo de
agrupar a los electores afines a su
corriente política y separar a los de la
oposición esta práctica conocida como el
Jerry mandering ha afectado
particularmente a varios estados entre
ellos Ohio Aunque allí la población es
moderada la aplastante mayoría de los
representantes electos locales es
republicano aquí la historia de Fania
[Música]
a ver si se acuerde este es uno de los
condados más pobres y más pequeños de
Ohio
Ohio ubicado en el noreste de Estados
Unidos es un estado con cerca de 12
millones de habitantes 54% son
republicanos 46% demócratas sin embargo
tras el último escrutinio la mayoría de
los representantes electos resultaron
ser republicanos sí la gente vota cuando
hay una elección pero como los distritos
están manipulados ya se sabe de antemano
Quién va a ganar es lo que acaba de
pasar en Ohio y los electores no pueden
hacer mucho al respecto tenemos
elecciones cada dos años entonces las
personas creen que participan pero los
resultados están encantados el sistema
está dañado David paper se ha dedicado a
luchar contra el sistema dañado este
expresidente del partido demócrata de
Ohio denuncia el Jerry mandering una
práctica casi tan antigua como la
democracia estadounidense que sirve para
rediseñar la circunscripciones a
conveniencia del partido en poder para
entender este fenómeno David nos lleva a
la ciudad de Manchester
Esta es la entrada de Manchester Ohio
una ciudad que existe desde hace más de
un siglo y así es como se ve los
representantes electos en Columbus
capital del Estado toman el dinero de
ciudades como esta para concederle
reducciones de impuestos a las personas
muy adineradas en vez de invertir en
algo que permitiría reactivar estas
ciudades es una locura Durante los
últimos 10 años el parlamento de ha
reducido en mil millones de dólares por
año el presupuesto destinado a gastos
locales una medida que ha afectado a
todos los sectores públicos escuelas
policías salud e infraestructuras
Cómo era la ciudad hace 40 años todos
estos edificios estaban ocupados
Sí ahí había una joyería
[Música]
eso era una carnicería y allá
había una lavandería en Manchester Ohio
los recortes del presupuesto se sumaron
al cierre de la central de carbón en
2018 desde entonces los representantes
electos no han votado ninguna inversión
importante para la comunidad
esta ciudad dice mucho sobre el estado
de la Democracia
porque hace unos años los habitantes
hablaron con su senador y le pidieron
ayuda para luchar contra el deterioro de
la ciudad pues después de haberlos
escuchado el senador les contestó que a
veces la única solución es mudarse Eso
lo dice todo aquí las circunscripciones
siempre se manipulan Entonces los
políticos aseguran su reelección sin
importar lo que pase
En otras palabras poco importa lo que
hagan porque no temen la sanción de las
urnas
si pasara lo mismo en otro país lo
consideraríamos como un ataque a la
democracia Pero como estamos en Estados
Unidos y estamos orgullosos de nuestra
democracia no nos damos cuenta
[Música]
en Washington la división de la
circunscripciones por partidos es una
práctica muy conocida withers aconseja a
los representantes y senadores
republicanos desde hace 40 años para él
la práctica del jardin van derin hace
parte de la política estadounidense
el yerry mandarín existe desde que
tenemos una República constitucional
no es algo exclusivo de un partido o de
otro si los demócratas están frustrados
en Ohio es porque los republicanos están
en el poder
pero les garantizo que si van al estado
de Nueva York a California o a Illinois
donde los demócratas están en el poder
verán que hay republicanos
en todos los estados la
circunscripciones son rediseñadas cada
diez años después del censo nacional esa
redistribución territorial permite que
el partido con mayoría descoja a sus
electores según criterios sociales
religiosos e incluso raciales Aunque
ambos partidos practican el Jerry en
2010 los republicanos lanzaron el
proyecto red Matt que les permitió ganar
un máximo de legislaturas
en 2010 los republicanos destinaron
Muchos medios financieros para que sus
candidatos fueran elegidos en los
parlamentos de los estados es porque son
los legisladores de los estados quienes
trazan los mapas y como ese proyecto
salió bien actualmente y desde hace 10
años los republicanos tienen ventaja
para rediseñar la circunscripciones
Por eso hay más republicanos haciendo
Jerry manderín
[Música]
una ventaja aún más significativa en la
actualidad porque los republicanos se
han servido de herramientas digitales
nuevas que les permiten analizar los
distritos como nunca antes jenn Miller
dirige la liga de electores de Ohio que
lucha contra el yerry madering
miren todas estas formas extrañas están
ahí porque los cartógrafos han utilizado
tecnologías avanzadas para entender las
intenciones de voto de los electores
dentro de los hogares
entonces cortan dividen y descomponen
los condados las comunidades y las
ciudades para asegurar una mayoría
republicana que de otra manera no
existiría
por ejemplo debes de hacer un solo
bloque pero los dividieron en dos para
diluir las voces de los demócratas
este tipo de formas demuestran que en
cada Distrito han tratado de escoger uno
por uno los hogares Y los electores que
salen a votar
en 2021 la liga de lectoras de Ohio
presentó dos quejas contra los mapas
electorales del parlamento de estado la
Corte Suprema de Ohio falló en su favor
considerando que los mapas eran
anticonstitucionales pero era demasiado
tarde para ejecutar la sentencia las
últimas elecciones de medio término se
llevaron entonces a cabo a partir de
unos mapas que le volvían a conceder una
amplia mayoría de los republicanos estos
son los resultados del 8 de noviembre en
la cámara 64 escaños contra 35 en el
senado 25 escaños contra 8
El senado Está peor que antes
Aunque la Corte Suprema de Ohio haya
considerado que estos mapas son
inconstitucionales actualmente los
ciudadanos se enfrentan a una mayor
distribución partidaria En el parlamento
la atención suele centrarse en el
congreso de Estados Unidos porque ahí se
deciden todas las leyes federales pero
aquí en Ohio el parlamento se pronuncia
sobre leyes relacionadas con el acceso
al voto el aborto y los derechos de los
jóvenes lgbtq esas decisiones dependen
de la cámara y del senado de Ohio y
tienen un impacto directo sobre la vida
de los habitantes varios proyectos de
ley se han centrado Precisamente en los
jóvenes transgénero tratando de limitar
sus derechos
uno de ellos está orientado a impedir
que las niñas transgénero participen en
equipos de deporte femenino en las
escuelas con 17 años ember Fue la
primera transgénero de Ohio en jugar
sóftbol de alto nivel
estos son los uniformes de verano de mi
equipo
mezclamos los colores
a mí me gusta mucho la combinación del
verde y el negro durante la pubertad en
vernos soportó el cambio de su voz y
dejó de hablar durante dos años
pero encontró un refugio en este deporte
me encanta me ha permitido encontrar una
comunidad
un ambiente seguro
tengo amigas me ha dado confianza en mí
misma
antes de poder integrarse a su equipo
ember tuvo que someterse a múltiples
pruebas para demostrar que sus
capacidades físicas no eran superiores a
la de las otras jóvenes
imaginar que podría ser expulsada le
molesta mucho
la mayoría no quiere que sean elegidos y
sin embargo siempre terminan ganando por
la redistribución electoral manipulada
nuestras voces no cuentan como deberían
para que haya una representación justa
de la población de Ohio en su conjunto
desde 2015 tan solo 13 jóvenes
transgénero hacen parte de equipos de
deporte en la secundaria entonces la ley
sólo aplicaría a unos cuantos entre
cientos de miles de alumnos para la
madre de Denver Esa es la consecuencia
directa de una política de extrema
derecha
actualmente en nuestro país las
organizaciones cristianas conservadoras
realmente quieren hacer presión para que
se aprueben leyes contra las personas
transgénero
me enfurece saber que mis impuestos
pagan una legislación que practica la
discriminación legal y que yo no estoy
ni siquiera mínimamente representada
tanto la representante como el senador
de nuestro Distrito apoyan esas leyes y
nuestra representante ni siquiera acepta
hablar conmigo a pesar de mi solicitudes
este año en verbo todo por primera vez
en las elecciones de medio término
Aunque parezca inútil es fundamental que
votemos sino es darse por vencido
[Música]
no darse por vencida es exactamente lo
que hizo Amy Cox esta candidata
demócrata a la cámara de Ohio se
presentó en una circunscripción donde
sabía que no tenía ninguna posibilidad
de ganar pero para esta antigua
profesora Lo importante es proponer una
alternativa no quiero tratar de ganar en
esta circunscripción porque no puedo
ganar es imposible está trazada para mi
adversario hice campaña para informar a
los electores sobre las elecciones
legislativas del estado cerca de 119,000
personas viven en la circunscripción
donde se presentó Amy pero tan solo un
tercio votó el 8 de noviembre Ella es
una vecina es republicana pero me conoce
y me apoya
los que viven ahí también son
republicanos
pero con ellos ni siquiera lo intento
porque no quieren hablar de política
conmigo
con 28% de los votos contra 72% para su
adversario republicano
hoy regresa para hablar con los
electores de sus circunscripción
Hola cómo estás bien y tú querías saber
si estabas satisfecho con los resultados
de la elección Ya lo habíamos comentado
desafortunadamente nuestro condado es
como si hubiera solo un partido y aunque
yo sea republicano voto por la persona
que me parezca competente no solo por
una etiqueta
el partido demócrata de Ohio solo le
ayuda a financiar su campaña a los
candidatos que tengan una posibilidad de
ganar para compensar esta situación
David pepper creó la organización Blue
Ohio Ohio azul el color político les
demócratas
si logramos tener miles de participantes
entonces cada candidato potencial en
Ohio sabrá que estamos ahí para apoyarlo
no solo con 200 dólares esta vez fueron
alrededor de 5000 y en unos años quizás
puedan ser 10 o 12.000 dólares
[Música]
y ya tiene más de mil cien miembros el
objetivo de David pepper es devolver el
poder a los electores
al trazar esos mapas manipulados su
objetivo es que ningún demócrata se
presente ni siquiera quieren que los
electores tengan la posibilidad de
escoger ni que su candidato tenga que
rendir cuentas por eso lanzamos Blue
Ohio para animar a los candidatos
a pesar de que sea difícil y estamos
orgullosos de haber apoyado a esos
candidatos porque si no se presentan eso
permite que los republicanos tengan el
monopolio y es lo que lleva el
extremismo
el aborto los derechos de las personas
transgénero o incluso el exceso de las
urnas actualmente están en peligro en 23
estados
[Música]
si bien la atención se suele concentrar
en Washington los derechos fundamentales
de los estadounidenses en realidad se
juegan a escala local
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima